you know what's having a conversation
with a friend writing on the phone and
she's also an entrepreneur
she runs a business her business does
around a million dollars a year and I
asked her a question and I think if
there's anything I can tell you with top
performers on any kind of a team any
kind of a business there's one thing you
can always do with them you know how if
somebody writes you check have you ever
had somebody write a check to you and it
bounced how annoying is it pretty
annoying gaining it I think we've all
had it happen to us at one point or
another when it check bounces well when
you're running in a business and
everyone's got their own
responsibilities everyone's got their
own little red wagon that they got a
pole you know what it's like when
somebody gives you commitment to a team
when you run a startup when you run a
business everyone's got to pull their
own weight imagine when a team sits
together and all the leaders give their
own commitments to you we're gonna do
this we're gonna do that I promise you
our departments gonna do this our
divisions gonna do this our
organizations gonna do this much
business to smile we're gonna deliver on
this you know what it's like when they
give a number and they don't hit it
that's that means I can't cash your word
maybe it's not cashing your check but I
can't cash your word and typical high
achievers you're never ever gonna catch
anybody 100% of the time in the sales
environment or the business environment
but I gotta be able to cash your word
80% at a time I've got to be able to
cash your award 80% of the time when you
make a commitment knowing yep that
person that girl that guy is going to do
whatever they can to do the commitment
that's been given so question for you
are you the type of person that if
you're running in an environment with
their sales and business involved and
you give your word can we catch your
word is that a yes can that award be
cashed or will that ward bounce like a
check bounces no Walt likes to see your
check balance if you want to be a real
serial entrepreneur your checks gotta
cash your words got a cash work on
- in your word it'll make you Millions
and they'll get a lot of people who
under business with you forever - come
anyways what's thinking about that
driving right on my buddy TomTom say
hello to everybody in the world of value
taming let's go cash some words let's go
catch some checks everybody have a good
day
Patrick wait David value taming take
care bye-bye